comedy I really truly believe this and
this is why I got into copy in the first
place it causes change and if you tell
the truth and you do in a funny way you
can cause great social change and Jack
hey you were the first african-american
woman to ever win an Emmy for no that's
is it still so for supporting actress
wait I think that was 1989 am i right
yes you're absolutely right yeah and I'm
a firm believer that though you know
those shows around that time from two to
seven and amen Cosby Show for me they
allowed America to see black people in a
different way which then had something
to do I believe with having a black
president and now you're you're playing
a character on a show that's about about
president it's art imitating life
imitating art in law I love it um and
that was no character by the way he
wrote that in yeah I came to your
designer grandmother the part that Marla
Gibbs us doing yeah I was gonna do that
part and then he said oh you ain't about
the story I mama no I'm not hey Marla
said okay I'll take it I'm gonna leave
that alone yeah wait so but do you did
you realize at the time when you're
doing this stuff like how important that
is I didn't realize that another
african-american woman hasn't won I do
now but not then yes I figured in
another world you know we'll come along
but you don't do that I didn't do it for
that purpose you know but uh it's great
you know but I would like another one to
happen so that's what I'm about
mentoring that's why all the the daily
tweets in the morning affirmation so
that you could feel better and get it
done go to work and sink your teeth into
its don't be afraid cuz sometimes women
we pull back yeah but we've been taught
that way because you know we don't want
to be noticed it's not modesty and all
that but you know my Angela modesty must
fall away like a cloak so you know so
now yeah so that's that's what it's
about well one thing that I think is
really cool about Big Bang is you guys
have made nerd culture and being smart
actually feels cool suddenly is that
something that you're very aware of that
like you guys are talking about science
all the time you have great scientists
on the show you had Stephen Hawking I
mean you've had some amazing people on
there do you feel that like it's
actually doing something good beyond
just making people laugh absolutely
absolutely i think it's it's really
special just you know on on tape
are fantastic warm-up comedian asked the
audience what this show means to them
and we get to hear how be a lot of the
audience feels that this is the first
time that we've seen characters like
this portrayed on TV and people who like
the things that this that a lot of this
country like that we has not a light has
not been shown on that point I think
they do such a fantastic job of that
yeah do you feel like it's like all
these nerds coming out of the closet I
have to illegally I in this show I have
to make one gay reference somehow but I
feel like the nerds are getting like
Julian leave a on this paper work here
you know one way to air it just has one
gay Rep one day reference that's it um
yeah that it's like all these nerds are
finally getting some what they're
getting validated by you guys it's
really cool it's it's very cool i mean i
was a nerd growing up I mean a different
kind of nerd sure like a theater yeah
like a theater a comedy nerd obviously
doing impressions yeah sure show and
tell but um and I think it's really cool
I think that we've all been under dogs
at some point in our life and it's and
it's really cool to see a group of
underdogs who are doing their thing and
they're smart and they're successful and
it's really nice and I also like the
fact that it's you know both myself and
mine play scientists on the show and
it's two female characters both playing
scientist whereas I think you know a lot
of times you would say like okay well
that'll be the scientist character and
then that's it and it's a group of smart
people who are all doing something in
that field which i think is really it's
really great and mimes isn't she a
neuroscientist in real life yeah yeah
she is yeah for real she's heavy really
mm-hmm oh my and beyond wow do you refer
to her as dr. behind them I do behind
the scene I do it took me a while first
I was just calling her blossom and then
she let me call her doctor yeah pretty
good mm-hmm uh well because I mentioned
the coming out of the closet a jacket I
know that the gays who
love you what what is it about you that
you think the gays just adore hey man
gave me my name I'm afraid to scheels
Jackie yes and I've dressing and then
been with them enough I've been in love
with gay man you know and people we said
what does that mean I said love has
nothing to do with sexuality or choices
it just has to do with love you know so
it's just a connection you know what I
mean it's not just because you're gay I
don't like all gay men but imma found
one I don't what is it but don't you
think there's something because you're
so infectious and there's something so
warm about you that gay people for some
reason are always attracted to that sort
of like a moth to a flame they always
love people that are sort of bigger than
I love the same movies and Sunset
Boulevard my foot one of my favors I
made you know it sounds very theatrical
yes you know I but I think it just
happened I mean it's like Bette Midler
who I loved growing up you know it's
just something you have or you don't you
know it's not something you are you know
what I mean I know and what's a speaking
of the gay thing I have to reveal a
little something that you and my grandma
were literally the only two people that
when I came out they said oh I thought
maybe I didn't know your grandma my
grandma said that she was in the third
of the theater in the 30s so she thought
which really wasn't even true it's a
whole that's a whole by side family
story but can you explain to the good
people why you thought maybe that I was
I believe it involves a drink that I
might have ordered oh I forgot yes I
didn't i say to you cuz you ordered a
mojito yeah a mojito Jackie does a
mojito strike you as a gauge ranked No
and yet i order had to be there that's
one of those yeah mm-hmm okay now what
did i order those game ya know you were
my hero yeah you were joking yeah I'm I
thought to me you I thought the movie I
didn't drink a mojito for 10 years after
that
bonobos calms the official outfitter of
the Ruben report enter code trr 20 for
twenty percent off your first purchase